welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight this
is Fox News Alert one of the most
extraordinary moments in the history of
social media is unfolding right now as
we speak and it began when Elon Musk
took control of Twitter when he bought
the company he promised to reveal its
corruption the extent to which Twitter
had engaged in politically motivated
censorship
including the unlawful the legal
censorship of American citizens at the
direction of the U.S government
well tonight less than an hour ago musk
began to make good on that promise
Twitter shared a trove of internal
documents with Matt taibi of sub stack
those documents are coming out again as
we speak and what they proved so far is
very serious
those documents show a systemic
violation of the First Amendment the
largest example of that in modern
history
these documents show that among other
things political officials in the
Democratic National Committee were
directing censorship at Twitter ahead of
the 2020 election
one Twitter official wrote on October
24th 2020 that he had received quote an
additional report from the DNC so the
DNC was telling Twitter what to pull off
the site and Twitter was complying next
morning
to prove it a Twitter official confirmed
the post had been deleted I grabbed the
first one that Twitter employee wrote
Twitter's also following instructions
directly from the Biden campaign in the
final days
of the presidential campaign
one of the documents proves that
officials on the Biden team routinely
directed Twitter to remove posts that
reflected poorly on Joe Biden quote more
to review from the Biden team read one
internal email from a Twitter employee
just days before the 2020 election that
email included a list of several Twitter
accounts that had criticized Joe Biden
the reply quote handled we just checked
now those accounts remain suspended
today
so Twitter was permanently censoring
users at the request of the DNC and the
Biden campaign that is new many
suspected it now it has been absolutely
confirmed by internal documents and of
course the New York Post Twitter account
was banned why because they had a story
that might have changed the outcome of
the 2020 election and Twitter knew that
perfectly well they had accurate
information about Hunter Biden's laptop
the post reporting directly implicated
Joe Biden and the Biden family in an
ongoing scheme to sell influence to
leverage Biden's job as a government
official to sell the prestige and the
power of the US government to China and
Ukraine
that scheme that ongoing scheme that
unfolded over years made the Biden
family millions of dollars ten percent
of that money was reserved as you know
for the big guy meaning Joe Biden
so that was information that might have
changed the outcome of the election and
that is precisely why Twitter prevented
its users from reading it
Twitter went so far as to block its
users from privately sharing the New
York Post story on Twitter direct
message so anyone attempting to share
the story about Hunter Biden's laptop
was told it was unsafe
now that measure preventing users from
sharing information privately is
something that Twitter reserves in
normal circumstances only in the most
extreme cases type B writes like
stopping the transmission transmission
of child pornography
but in this case information that might
have hurt Joe Biden's chances of
becoming president were invoked
and they were applied even to the
sitting president's press secretary
Kaylee mcineny
internally taibi writes quote the
decision was made at the highest levels
of the company but without the knowledge
of CEO Jack Dorsey with former head of
legal policy and Trust by Jaya Gotti
playing a key role
all suspected now confirmed now in
public Twitter and its many allies and
the rest of the media claimed that the
New York Post story violated the Hacked
materials policy that Twitter had on its
books but internally at Twitter everyone
understood that was just a pretext the
laptop had not been hacked and it wasn't
of Russian origin and by the way as of
right now it's 804 eastern time there is
no evidence in this ongoing thread for
Matt taibi that Twitter had received
confirmation from the U.S government
even
that the laptop was fake or from Russia
they just made it up
according to taibi one official admitted
that quote hacking was the excuse but
within a few hours pretty much everyone
at Twitter realized that wasn't going to
hold but no one had the guts to reverse
it
One Communications official at Twitter
Trenton Kennedy wrote this quote I'm
struggling to understand the policy
basis for marking this the laptop story
is unsafe
Twitter's former head of trust and
safety UL Roth explained that Twitter
had to censor the story so that Donald
Trump would not be re-elected president
quote the policy basis is hacked
material though as discussed this is an
emerging situation where the facts
remain unclear given the severe risks
here and the lessons of 2016 meaning
Trump could get elected we're airing on
the side of including a warning and
preventing this content from being
Amplified
now this played out to some extent in
public now we know what was happening
within Twitter but the whole country
knew
that something was being censored a lot
of people couldn't read it but it was
widely known that Twitter was censoring
this and so by the way were many other
news organizations and at that time
Twitter received a communication from a
consultant in Washington who had taken
an informal poll of members of Congress
Democrats and the message this person
sent to Twitter was Democrats in
Congress support the censorship and were
quoting they don't think the first
amendment is absolute
in other words sitting members of
Congress were encouraging censorship to
affect the outcome of a presidential
election that is illegal it is
effectively election rigging and it is a
direct attack on our Bill of Rights by
people who have sworn to uphold the Bill
of Rights
you gotta hope someone will be held
accountable for this
so back to the documents within Twitter
others presumably all voting Democrats
but some with some Integrity kept
raising questions about this former vice
president of Global Communications
Brandon Borman asked quote can we
truthfully claim this is part of the
policy in other words is this consistent
with the rules
then the general counsel of Twitter Jim
Baker that would be the former FBI
general counsel who was directly
involved in the FBI's interview with
Michael Flynn when his life was
destroyed for political reasons signed
off
on the continued censorship the former
FBI official signed off quote caution is
warranted said Baker
let's hope we hear from Mr Baker in a
congressional hearing very soon
so throughout all of this the record
shows at least as of right now only one
elected official in the entire
Democratic party that would be rokana of
Silicon Valley a Democrat
voicing any concern at all
so Connor reached out to Vijaya Gotti
and here's what he wrote this seems to
be a violation of the First Amendment
principles and I say this as a total
Biden partisan
but he was completely blown off by the
jagadi by the way good for him
he's a liberal too but apparently sort
of a real one within days someone called
Carl Sabo the research from net Choice
advised Twitter Executives that on
Capitol Hill Democrats were very happy
with this they supported the censorship
so as we said this thread exposing
internal documents from Twitter as
transcribed with commentary by Matt
taibi is so ongoing it is still flowing
forth as we speak we'll bring you
information as it comes subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight